let's talk about away from zaparia let's
talk about the ukrainian offensive it
started on monday it's in the south day
four how's it going yes um kimberly it's
going quite quickly and it's a big
offensive it's about 160 kilometers in a
big arc from uh southwest of um uh
curson right round uh to the north uh
and at the moment there's a there's a
quite a big breakthrough at uh velika
kostronko which is only a village but
the reason that that's quite important
is that that is the area that controls
the road down to nova kokovka which is a
very important hydroelectric plant
there's the dam there which controls the
water to crimea and what this tells us
is that the ukrainians in a way going
for broke here that they have they've
got two objectives they're trying to
liberate kirsten and get hold of
novakovka and so this big offensive is
pretty um uh
ambitious
it's got to move quickly and it looks as
if the ukrainians are moving on about
four breakthrough lines in this very
long 160 mile kilometer front so we'll
see how it goes but this is what we've
been waiting to see can they really do
it they're they're giving it uh quite a
big shot here
and they will want to try to capture
both of those places within a matter of
weeks i guess so is that the end game
those two places or do you see this
going even further they're not saying
and and we don't know this is my
interpretation but if you look at where
they're putting their forces it's pretty
clear that they're not just trying to
take cursion they're trying to
encircle all the russian troops who are
west of the nipah river this is the
nipah river the russians have got about
20 000 troops in this area and if they
can actually encircle them if they can
threaten to cut them off the idea must
be that if russian forces feel that
they're getting cut off they will have
to withdraw from cursor they may have to
withdraw from nova novakovka and what
that means is that the ukrainians then
can take back the city they really want
the only big city the russians hold
without having to fight for it without
shelling it which they obviously don't
want to do they want to put the russians
in a situation where the russians have
to withdraw that i think is what they're
trying to achieve okay away from the
ukraine but still on the same sort of
subject we've had the news in the last
hour that um vladimir putin is not going
to attend mikhail gorbachev's funeral
it's being held on saturday
they um they um they said that he's paid
his tribute today whatever that means
but he's not going to this funeral what
do you make of that yes i mean vladimir
putin does not want to be identified
with gorbachev i mean gorbachev is a
very unpopular figure in russia he's an
extremely popular figure in the rest of
the world because he was the man who
effectively ended the cold war from the
point of view of the soviet union but he
lost control of what he was trying to do
he was a decent man he wasn't always he
wasn't always a a pacifist i mean he
sent the tanks into tubisi in georgia
into azerbaijan
he sent tanks into lithuania but when
the big demonstrations occurred when
eastern europe was clearly
desperate for change he did not send the
tanks in then and he didn't send the
tanks in when the soviet union collapsed
the soviet union went out of business in
december 1991 it was astonishing it just
they ended they finished um after 70 80
years and so putin does not want to be
identified with that because putin is
trying to recreate all the things that
he thinks that gorbachev gave away and
so his um
you know his lack of sympathy for
gorbachev i think is is indeed indicated
by the way he's trying to nuance his
tributes to him yeah tribute pay today
but won't be at the funeral okay
professor michael clark thank you so
much